so hi everyone um it's a pleasure to be
speaking um at the bio conference live
today i'm going to be talking about
practical considerations for the
clinical interpretation
of germline sequence variants in the air
of next generation sequencing my name is
heather mclaughlin and i'm currently an
assistant laboratory director at the
laboratory for molecular medicine
my office is in cambridge massachusetts
and i'm also
an instructor at harvard medical school
and the massachusetts general hospital
so in terms of starting out i just
wanted to do a brief disclosure as i
said i am an employee for the laboratory
for molecular medicine and we are a fee
for service genetic laboratory
and i briefly wanted to give an outline
of my talk so um we're going to start
out by
um talking about the evolution of
clinical molecular genetics so where
have we been and sort of where are we
going in the future
um talk a little bit about what is
varian interpretation um
i have a lot of case examples to show
you with interpretation considerations
and pitfalls and then we'll end by
learning about how to construct variant
interpretations to put on clinical
reports
um oh and i forgot to say at the
beginning if anyone has any questions um
feel free to put them in the q a and
then i'll try to address them at the end
if we have some time
so
um as many of you um probably realize
the evolution of clinical molecular
genetics is really growing so we started
out several years ago doing um just
genotyping and during that time
um interpretation of sequence variance
wasn't really required because by
definition we were looking for variants
that we already knew were pathogenic
however as things have evolved to go to
single gene sequencing and then onto
gene panels which can contain anywhere
from five to hundreds of genes and now
eczema and genome which include
thousands and thousands of genes um
the need for
variant interpretation has greatly
increased
so in terms of our experience at the
laboratory for molecular medicine we
have now done perform diagnostic testing
for over 15 000
pro bands and we cover many different
disease areas ranging from
cardiomyopathy to hearing loss to
pulmonary disorders
and one thing that we have noticed over
time i think at the beginning we sort of
expected that
after a while we would
sort of see all the novel variation and
some of the genes that we're testing
but in fact this is not the case so as
you can see on my slide here about 68
percent
of pro bands have
a likely pathogenic or pathogenic
variant that we only see a single time
and 96 of variants are seen less than 10
times so what this really means for us
in terms of variant interpretation is
that this is going to be a long process
i don't think it's going to end anytime
soon
and
in every single case that you see there
are many many new variants
that are identified in patients that
need to be assessed for pathogenicity
so what are we talking about when um
we're talking about varian
interpretation i think the questions are
pretty simple um the first is does the
variant disrupt protein
or gene function and therefore protein
function
um the second question is can this
disrupted function lead to disease
and then the third and probably most
important question for clinical reports
is is this disrupted gene function
causative for my patient's presentation
so the varian assessment process that we
have established here at the laboratory
for molecular medicine um brings in a
lot of pieces
of variant interpretation so usually
what happens um we run a lot of next
generation sequencing tests so we'll get
the lab result that will have
various variants that um
have been identified in that individual
and then we really get to work trying to
do the variant annotation so we look at
a lot of things we look at published and
in-house data we look at segregation
studies that are available from that
published data and then also within the
family itself
we look at things like population
frequency amino acid conservation
pathogenicity prediction splicing tools
so all of those things go into a variant
interpretation and then we take that
knowledge
um along with the clinic of data and the
custom knowledge that we have about the
gene or disease area and perform a
variant classification and i'm going to
talk a little bit more about
the criteria that we use to provide
these variant classifications that i've
described below
but in general
we have
the five variant classification
categories that have been proposed by
the american college of medical genetics
and genomics so this ranges from benign
all the way to pathogenic um and then on
our clinical reports we choose not to
report back the benign variants but
anything that's like likely benign to
the u.s to likely path or pass is put on
the clinical report
and a lot of times what we see is that
if we
do family testing and have more
segregation data or if we gather
additional info we kind of come back to
this variant classification sometimes
and indeed sometimes the variant
classification will change based on this
information so
the process is sort of fluid and
things can
progress either way depending on what
kind of information that you have
so next i wanted to just go go through
some of the
items that i've listed that go into the
variant annotation process
and sort of talk about common pitfalls
and things to think about when we're
looking at these
um so the first thing i want to talk
about is population frequency and i've
provided a couple of websites here that
we commonly use to gather population
frequency info so the nhbli exome
sequencing project
server is is a great one and that has a
lot of information for european
americans and african americans
and then db sniffing 1000 genomes also
has
several other populations
and what we're really asking when we're
looking at
population frequency is compared to the
prevalence of the disease or phenotype
that we're trying to assess
is this variant rare
so for example one of the
diseases that we test in our laboratory
is cardiomyopathy
and so if we saw a variant um below in
this example nybpc3
we see that this missense change is
present at a minor allele frequency or
maf
of 1.4 percent in african americans
so when we're going to assess a variant
like this
in the back of our minds we know that
the prevalence of hypertrophic
cardiomyopathy um if that was the
patient's indication is about one in 500
or 0.2 percent we can automatically know
that 1.4 minor allele frequency for a
variant even if this was the single the
only disease-causing variant in the
entire um
gene or only for hcm which we know isn't
the case um the variant frequency is
much too high to be causative for
mendelian disease so automatically a
variant like this we would be we would
suspect to be more likely benign
there are a lot of common pitfalls
in
looking at population frequency so the
first one is that indels are troublesome
and this is because
of the way that insertion deletion
variants are aligned so sometimes it can
be
very difficult to to tell if
these variants are actually in public
are actually absent from public
databases because
sometimes the data quality
isn't
all that good and so it may look like
the variant isn't present
in some of these databases when in fact
it was just a data quality issue
population cohorts are also somewhat
homogeneous so i mentioned that in the
esp
cohort on the previous slide
um it it basically covers european
americans and african americans so if
you're sequencing populations or
individuals who aren't
represented in those populations we need
to be very cautious because it's going
to be difficult for us to determine if
a variant that we find is part of the
benign spectrum of variation in that
population or if it truly is a rare
variant and there really is no way to
tell until we have a good um
a good control population
um the other thing is on the previous
slide i just showed you how we can use
population frequency and data and
prevalence estimates to
determine if a variant may be pathogenic
and in that example hcm is a really
well-studied disease and we we think we
have a pretty good grasp on the
prevalence of that disease but many
diseases especially ones that are more
rare
have
prevalence estimates that are sort of
more guesstimates and so it can be
really difficult to compare the
frequency um to disease prevalence so
the example that i gave in in the last
slide we have to be really careful when
we're using
population frequencies to
infer pathogenicity
um another issue um to think about is
reduced penetrance so we deal with this
a lot in our lab in terms of
cardiomyopathy because some individuals
who have pathogenic variants do not
display the disease and in this case um
it may lead
to the variant existing at a higher
population frequency that might be
expected due to less selective pressure
so that's something to always keep in
consideration
um and then of course on the flip side
recessive variants may also be present
at high frequency so
some really common pathogenic variants
for example delta
delta f 508 and cftr
is present at a a little bit higher
frequency um than other pathogenic
variants so a lot of recessive variants
um
are that way
and then one final thing to think about
is that high frequency variants may
still impart some disease risk so
there's a variant that we um
come across sometimes in our lab in
scn5a the minor allele frequency is
actually quite high at seven percent in
african americans however um published
studies have shown that this may be a
risk allele for arrhythmia and the odds
ratio is about 2.5 so instead of calling
this variant benign just based on the
allele frequency alone we may still want
to include it on the report
we might be able to say it's probably
benign for mendelian disease but it
might still impart a disease risk
so in terms of conservation analysis i
think everybody's sort of probably
familiar with this concept and what
we're really asking is has the effect of
nucleotide or amino acid resisted change
throughout evolution so i've given an
example here of two amino acids one with
quite high conservation and then one was
low conservation
and one thing that we also can look at
is nucleotide conservation and
looking at the presence of a nucleotide
change in other species as well so you
can kind of do it both at the amino acid
level and at the nucleotide level
i think the
the big take-home point here is that
lack of conservation may indicate that
the variant could be benign and it's not
really just lack of conservation that
we're looking for it's actually the
variant amino acid present in another
species so let's say i have a threonine
to alanine change and alanine is present
in many many mammals
i might not expect that variant to be
to be pathogenic however if you have a
situation like this low
conservation variant that i'm showing
here
the only thing that we can say is that
cysteine and serine seem to be tolerated
but we cannot say that other amino acids
may not be tolerated just because this
is low conservation
so i think um
a huge point to take home here is that
um a variant with extensive conservation
by itself um does not really provide
evidence for pathogenicity on its own um
it's just saying that that variant um
is um or that amino acid position rather
is well conserved so we should never be
using conservation analysis alone to
classify a variant
um i next wanted to talk about the
subject of pathogen pathogenicity
prediction so i've listed a couple of
programs here there are certainly
several others and most of these tend to
use a combination of
conservation amino acid characteristics
and protein structure
um to infer pathogeny for missense
variants
and i'm going to give an example on the
next slide sort of the output that we
might see for these so this is just an
excel table of
various outputs um for some of these and
i've tried to indicate in red if the
call would um
would say that this variant was
pathogenic and orange if it's possibly
pathogenic or in green if
the
prediction program is calling a variant
benign
so on the top here you can see that all
of these computational pathogenicity
prediction programs are an agreement
that the variant
may be pathogenic and on the bottom
they're all in agreement that it may be
benign
but the example that i'm providing in
the middle is usually something that we
see quite often which is that some of
them call the variant pathogenic and
then some of them
call them benign
so um the the big take-home point here
is that these are only predictions um
these pathogenicity prediction programs
should never be used to
directly classify
a variant i think it's okay to use them
as part of an overall interpretation
process but they shouldn't have a
significant influence on your
classification and it certainly
shouldn't overrule other sources of data
like allele frequency segregation with
disease functional data things like that
those
are much more stronger pieces of
evidence than pathogeny prediction
programs would be
i think sometimes people are sort of
surprised that you can't just use
these prediction programs to classify
variants but i think it's really
important to
use more genetic evidence and functional
evidence to classify variants
one other kind of prediction that we can
use are splicing predictions and a
program that we often use for this is
element and that's where the examples
are provided here but really what we're
asking um
is is um are the splice sites um sort of
affected or does a variant lead to the
creation of a novel splice site
so on the top here i've shown
an exon and you can see where the plus
minus one two spots are that are the
common slicing
um
positions and then also um the plus five
position which i've indicated with an
arrow which is um the fifth most
conserved base of um the splicing um
region
so um one gene where splicing variants
are commonly found in our pathogenic is
the mybpc3 gene and what i've shown here
is a variant that leads to the ablation
of a five prime
splice site so you can see that all the
pathogenicity prediction programs at the
top are calling this zero in a five
prime splice site but after this variant
change
we see that the splice site is abolished
and so that's really what we're looking
for when we're trying to decide if some
of these splicing predictions
are are giving us any information um i
think one other important thing to to
point out is that i think it's important
to look at splicing predictions even for
variants that are missing
um because sometimes we do see um
perhaps the creation of a novel spice
site so again this is the same gene my
bpc3 and we see that this variant even
though it is a missense variant um it
seems to be creating
a perhaps novel three prime splice site
so those are always things to keep into
consideration when you're looking at
splicing protections
um there are a lot of common pitfalls
with splicing prediction so the first
thing to notice is that a lot of these
algorithms are noisy so this is just a
snapshot
of a gene region and you can see that
many of the prediction programs are
calling five-frame splice sites sort of
all over the place
obviously um
many of these probably aren't real and
then there's also one um
program that's calling many three prime
splice sites all over this region and so
a lot of these probably aren't real so i
think you have to have an eye towards um
towards
false positives for these and and to
know that this again is just a
prediction algorithm and is not really
telling us
what's actually happening with the
splicing machinery
um certainly in vitro data um things
like mini gene assays that can support
the splicing predictions are excellent
to have however these may not always
represent biological function
and in vivo data so if we can get mrna
data from actual human individuals with
these variants
that is really best but unfortunately
from our experience that's rarely
available in the literature
um so just a word on nonsense frame
shift and one two slice variants so
these are commonly assumed to be
pathogenic and this is because of the
high likelihood of a severe impact to
the protein so nonsense and frame shifts
um usually lead to premature stops and
one two splice can lead to exon skipping
which would lead to a frame shift and a
premature stop uh we need to be careful
with these variants because although
most of them will be deleterious to the
protein not all of them
may result in disease and in fact there
are many genes where we know that we can
lose one copy of the gene
and be absolutely fine with no phenotype
another thing to be consideration
take into consideration is where
the variant is located so if loss of
function variant is occurring in the
last exon
it will likely um escape down since
mediated decay and may lead to a
truncated protein as opposed to an
absent protein
so an example of this is
a loss of function variant in the brca2
gene now normally loss of function
variants in brca 1 and 2
are considered to be pathogenic however
this particular variant resides in the
last exon
and on top of that we know that it's
present in uh 0.8 percent of european
americans
in the exome
sequencing project
so um what we think is probably happened
is that this variant likely escapes nmd
certainly the
population prevalence
or frequency of this variant is much too
high to be leading to mendelian bracha
one and two
associated cancer and so um
this variant has actually been
classified as likely benign by many
different laboratories
with respect to that so it's always good
to to kind of look at where the variant
is at
and then sometimes population frequency
data can give you a little bit more
information which is great
so review of published data again i've
just tried to provide a couple of
helpful resources the human genome
mutation database is great
clinvar is starting to be populated with
varying classifications from
many different laboratories and
if you're
in a laboratory that um hasn't
contributed yet i really encourage you
to contribute to this website i think
it'll be very important
and then there's also pubmed and
obviously many many locus specific
databases and the hdbs
website has a really great list of
databases for various diseases
so what are we really looking for when
we're talking about
published data obviously we really want
to try to find other patients or
families with this variant
it's really important to note the race
or ethnicity of these patients and
families
if there's any consanguinity
what the disease is so sometimes we see
variants and many different diseases and
so you really have to sort of parse that
out um
it's important to note if there are any
de novo occurrences of this variant
and then i think probably most
importantly is their segregation of this
variant with disease or actually
on the flip side does this variant not
segregate with disease
um
there are also a lot of case control
studies that you may be able to find in
the literature for certain variants and
certainly
functional studies and any time that we
can find an in-vivo study as opposed to
an in-vitro study that's all the more
better but
a lot of times we just have to take what
we can get
so in terms of reviewing published data
the first common pitfall i want to talk
about is race race and ethnicity
so
unfortunately as i alluded to before
when looking at population frequency
there is little data available for some
populations and a variant that you see
that comes out of clinical sequencing
may be a frequent variant in certain
ethnic or geographic populations so i
have an example here of a variant in the
ptpn11 gene
this gene is associated with newton's
syndrome and other associated disorders
so this variant had been previously
published as pathogenic in
several papers for noonan syndrome
it had been reported in seven provens of
the clinical features of noonan syndrome
but this variant had also been found in
two unaffected parents
and um
a patient received this variant back on
a report and decided to contact the
author of the paper and the author of
that paper said that he later found this
variant in 3.8 or 3 out of 80
ashkenazi jewish controls and that that
author now feels the variant is benign
our laboratory has identified this
variant in three ashkenazi jewish
programs um with noonan syndrome and now
we think this variant is likely benign
based on the high frequency in the
ashkenazi jewish population
and i think it's really important
this gene really illustrates why it's
important to think about race and
ethnicity and what population data is
available because
variants in the ptp and 11 gene are
oftentimes
used to make reproductive decisions so
we have a lot of women who receive
prenatal screening or prenatal
sequencing
for fetuses with increased nuclear
translucency and if we report a variant
like this out as pathogenic um there
could be um conception choices that are
being made based on this decision so
it's very very important for us to take
into consideration the race and
ethnicity of a patient when we are
assessing variants
another common footfall is consuming and
so
when we think about consanguinity by
definition we know that individuals who
result from consanguineous marriages
will exhibit a high degree of
autozygosity so basically what that
means is we're we expect to see many
large homozygous stretches throughout
the genome
so one variant that we came across
in a genome sequencing study when we
were doing an incidental findings
analysis was this variant in the med 25
gene
this variant was originally reported in
a large costa rican family with
autonomous recessive chakra marine tooth
disease and interestingly this variant
was found in all affected individuals so
that's 22 segregations and in the
genetic world in clinical genetics 22
segregation is huge we never see that
many segregations so this really was
quite a bit of evidence on towards this
variant being pathogenic and disease
however when we were doing an analysis
on this variant we noticed that in five
years since this original publication
no other reports of this varying or gene
in association with cmt or any other
diseases
have been reported even though we now
know that the minor allele frequency of
this variant is about half a percent um
in the exome sequencing project database
and so given that the minor allele
frequency is so high we would have
expected to at least see one additional
patient um
with this gene disease association and
so that kind of calls into question um
this variant and its role in disease and
i think
it's really important to think about
consanguinity in this situation because
what may be happening is that this
variant
um
may be tagging another
disease-associated variant
that is um
linked to this variant somewhere else on
the same chromosome and so we need to be
very careful even even when we have this
many segregations in families with
consensus especially if it's the only
time this variant has ever been reported
um one other thing that we commonly deal
with in our lab is non-segregation um
and so i'm going to talk about this
today in the context of cardiomyopathy
because non-segregation um
can occur sometimes um and i think um in
in the presence of genotype positive
phenotype negative individuals for some
disorders may be acceptable and so
cardiomyopathy is one of those um
instances because we know that this
disorder has both reduced penetrance and
late onset
so the top family that i'm showing you
here has a family so this 30 year old
individual with left ventricular
hypertrophy which would be a sign of
hypertrophic cardiomyopathy
and they also had arrhythmia and we know
that this individual had a family
history of sudden cardiac death
so they were positive
for a variant that we know to be
pathogenic in our lab
however this individual's brother was
also positive but not yet displaying
signs of disease
in this case this isn't really evidence
against disease especially because we've
already established that this variant
is pathogenic and so what will happen
for this individual is probably more of
a wait and see approach and
knowing that they have this variant and
that um
they their echo has been normal um
we will kind of just wait and see what
happens with that individual
this family also had an interesting
example because there was a
seven-year-old
individual who was tested um that had a
normal echo and again because this
individual is so young we might not
expect them to have
any signs of disease yet and so it will
also be sort of a wait and see approach
for them as well so i think this sort of
illustrates um
situations where you can have genotype
positive phenotype negative individuals
especially in disorders of reduced
penetrance or late onset
the second thing i wanted to talk about
although this is rare um it does happen
um that some families may have more than
one pathogenic variant segregating and
so
um this is an example of a family that
had both a titan and rbm 20 variant and
both of these genes are associated
with dilated cardiomyopathy
however if you did testing and only
tested for one of these variants
you would basically see that the variant
wasn't segregating with disease because
in some family members
they wouldn't have this variant but they
would still be affected but that's
probably because
um like the example of
this female individual on the right that
has dilated cardiomyopathy and only has
the titan variant
of why variant may not be segregating
also in these families um sometimes what
might happen if we have two variants
that are segregating sort of coming from
both sides of the family is sometimes we
have infants who have very severe
disease
and sort of
unfortunately succumb to that disease at
a very young age and usually those
individuals
will end up having both variants so a
lot of times if you have two pathogenic
variants um
for the same disease we see a much
higher degree
of the phenotype
so i wanted to take a moment now to talk
about case control studies just really
to try to hammer home the fact that you
have to have an adequate number of cases
and controls and hopefully these are
race matched in order for this
information to be
um
to be beneficial to you so i'm an
example of a lot of times what we see
is somebody will say a variant was found
in 100 cases and it was absent from 100
controls
well um so we have 100 cases in control
so that's 200 chromosomes so we've seen
the variant in one out of 200 versus
zero out of 200 chromosomes that p-value
is literally one it's it's very it's
meaningless to us so in order for this
to be meaningful we would need to screen
about at least two thousand chromosomes
to even reach a p value of point zero
five
um and again control should be rage race
match so um i would encourage you
especially in older papers that are that
are sort of um that had you know really
small populations that they were
screening and trying to
say that because they found the variant
in a couple of individuals but didn't
find it in any controls um when we're
only looking at a couple of hundred
individuals to begin with to really
to look at that data and to be wary of
some of the conclusions that are made
i've provided a link here which i think
is a really quick and easy way to do a
fischer's exact test so anytime that you
come across data like this in a paper
you can just put it in
to this test and it will calculate a
p-value for you
so now i wanted to come around full
circle we talked about a couple of
topics today that go into
variant interpretation and
um now i wanted to talk about after
we've gathered all this data and sort of
annotated this variant
with as much information as we can as we
have how do we actually perform the very
um classification process and assign
this variant of classification like
likely benign or is this variant a
variant of uncertain significance of the
u.s or is it pathogenic
so how do we do that
and um
i was going to quickly show today
this is a really exciting um
figure that has come out of the american
college of medical genetics and genomics
lab qa committee on the interpretation
of sequence variants and i've provided i
tried to fit it in at the bottom a link
at the below that
everyone can go in if you are an acmg
member you can view this content
but basically this this work group has
done a really excellent job of coming up
with um
sort of what
um
what strength of evidence is required to
call something pathogenic or benign and
um if we should consider the evidence
that we have in hand
supporting evidence so not really having
a lot of pull on the final variant
classification anywhere from moderate
evidence or very strong evidence
so i'm not going to spend too much time
on this slide hopefully everyone can
kind of go back later
and take a look but what i hope you can
appreciate is that
things like segregation are really make
things um
a variant maybe be more strong and some
of the things that we talked about today
like
um just looking at pathogenicity
prediction programs um may only provide
just supporting evidence
um
so i encourage everyone to to go to this
website and take a look at um
at the work that this lab qa committee
has done
um so once we're done and we've
classified a variant how do we construct
a variant interpretation
um so the contents of your
interpretations should include a lot of
the things that we've already talked
about
before so reports in the literature and
maybe any lab specific data that you may
have from testing this gene or disease
previously
we should always include the population
frequency of this data
any pathogenicity prediction programs
and conservation that we have seen any
functional data
um we should always know if the variance
is non-uh nonsense nonsense frame shift
or splice um that we would expect this
variant perhaps to lead to nonsense
media decay except if it's in the last
exon
and then we should say any gene or
disease specific information um that we
might have and sort of provide um
this with a summary sentence and so what
i wanted to do i'm just at the end of
the talk is just give a case example
this is a pretty easy
case example obviously it's not always
this easy but
in this case this was an individual who
came in
with an indication of hypertrophic
cardiomyopathy
this patient underwent genome sequencing
and surprisingly we found a variant in
ptpn11 which i talked about earlier this
gene is associated with noonan syndrome
and also leopard syndrome
um so
let's go um take a look at a couple of
um
these different things that we can look
at so the first is population frequency
and we notice that this variant was not
present in
the exome sequencing project database or
in a thousand genomes
this variant was pretty well conserved
down to zebrafish
in terms of passages pathogenicity
prediction programs this variant
was called benign by one prediction and
pathogenic by three prediction programs
there was no predicted effect on
splicing
and this is really the evidence that
we're looking for this so this variant
has been identified in over 40
individuals with leopard syndrome
it's segregated with disease and four
affected relatives and importantly this
variant has been
confirmed in novo
in multiple cases of leopard syndrome
and um functional data for this variant
um in vivo functional data actually
showed impaired catalytic activity
so what we would do for a variant like
this i just want to provide you with an
example of what a variant interpretation
might look like so i'm just going to
um
i'm not going to read this variant
interpretation out loud but i think this
is the kind of information that we want
to be providing on clinical reports
we want to state the facts um things
that we have found like the number of
individuals that has occurred and if
it's occurred to nova we want to be able
to cite
the manuscripts and the papers that we
have
found this data in
just so that our clinicians the genetic
counselors the patient even can go back
to any of these papers and sort of look
at the data themselves
so to start wrapping up here
variant interpretation cannot be done
without some sort of manual curation so
there is no
um
you know algorithm or program or
software that we can use to date that
can allow us to perform clinical grade
variant interpretations on variants
and although the guidelines are being
developed
professional judgment will still be
required so even using those guidelines
from
acmg i think you still have to use your
own professional judgment in your
disease area or for the gene that you're
looking at in order to
correctly classify a variant
um some variants may require a group
consensus
um and interpretations may change over
time we've seen that in our own lab so
we tend to reinterpret uh variance of
uncertain significance um every three to
six months and i think uh anytime a
clinician comes to you and asks about a
variant it really helps to sometimes
reinterpret that variant to see if um
there's any new literature or any new
information about that variant
um and then the last point i wanted to
make is that disease and gene specific
knowledge may be required um thankfully
in in the world of email and everything
else i think it's really easy to seek
external expertise about this if
you find a variant in a gene that you're
not familiar with
so i wanted to acknowledge at the end
partners personalized medicine
laboratory for molecular medicine that's
where
a lot of these cases came from and then
the gene insight team
which is the software program that we
use actually to keep track of our
varying assessments and interpretations
um
and i'm just going to leave it on this
slide here so i'm i am going to go to
the q a and try to answer a few
questions um if your question doesn't
get answered i have my
email address here on the screen and
people can feel free um to email me any
questions that you may have and then if
you're interested in the continuing
education credits there's a link here
um
so um
let's see
um some of the questions that we have so
one of the questions here is
from um dana from gene dx and it says
since genetics is moving so quickly how
often do you do a literature search for
variants that you have previously
reported um so i think i just um said
this a minute ago but we it depends on
the classification that we gave the
variant in the first place so
um a lot of times for pathogenic
variants our criteria is such that we
require um quite a few segregations and
a lot of data in order to call that
variant pathogenic so usually pathogenic
variants
rarely ever get assessed however for
variants of uncertain significance
especially because things are moving so
quickly you're absolutely correct um
we've decided to um
to take a look at those every three to
six months so anytime we come across a
variant again
um
we
basically by the time we see that
variant again we usually have to um do a
variant interpretation on it so um and
and i will say that um in our labs
experience that has although it's a lot
of work for some variants it really does
make a difference
because there is new data out there
um
and let's see
if i have any other questions um
so um the other question um
i have here is that um and this is from
barbara stout and it says if you have an
individual that has parents from
two different homogeneous populations
are the homogeneous population cohorts
still useful for
um prediction so
if you um
i think in most cases yes so for example
if you had um i think what you're asking
if you had an african-american um
individual who came from a homogeneous
population and you had
a caucasian individual that came from a
homogeneous population and those two
individuals made
you would still be able to use the
population frequency data
for those individuals however if there's
no population frequency data available
for that cohort
unfortunately you would not really be
able to use that
for
um for prediction of allele frequency
um
so i think um we're just about done with
questions like i said if anyone has any
questions please feel free
um
to um to email me and let me know and
i'd be more than happy to answer any
questions you might have
great thank you everybody